projet d'avant
pas moi
et bien hall sorel à quelques heures du
spectacle d'alain bashung on procède aux
dernières mises au point aux derniers
réglages de la sonorisation mais je peux
vous assurer que tout sera en place tout
en ordre pour le spectacle de tout à
l'heure combien de disques aujourd'hui
je crois que ça doit être entre 600 650
milles où je pense juste pas exactement
face à ces zones là ça fait un disque
d'or on se change simplement le fait que
je peux tourner avec un minimum de
matériel parce que bon quand on se
déplace et fo faut beaucoup de matériel
et puis avoir que deux le monde soit
content des rampes eux c'est une petite
entreprise quand même vous voyez comment
millions pour l'europe en france pour
tous et veulent s'en sortir dans 5 ans
et l'autre un bon aller au charbon
charbon tout le temps je fermais oui
c'est un guerrier côté là où ses doigts
mais quand tu es vraiment là haut
surtout contre la hollande et la hausse
est encore pire surtout pas se dire que
c'est facile vous travaillez un heads
il faut se faire chier il faut surtout
travailler quand c'est pas deux
alors